hey everyone
so i'm going to show you how to
integrate ammo.js into your three.js
projects giving you access to some nice
physics in the process
you can see from 3.js's example site
that they do sort of support physics
they've got a bunch of demos here
showing you that it is possible to
integrate physics into projects but once
you get into the source code it's not
quite as simple as just enabling it
we'll be focusing on ammo.js in
particular but you do have options for
javascript physics engines there's a
whole bunch of very capable ones
available
so ammo.js is really just a javascript
wrapper around another older and very
well-known physics engine the bullet
physics engine it's actually compiled
from c plus into javascript which in
itself is pretty neat and the general
approach for using it in your projects
goes like this you've got your game
world those are all your objects the
characters everything that kind of stuff
you could sort of imagine it as the true
world you've got your 3d world and
that's kind of a separate thing keep it
in sync to the real world by updating it
with the positions of things and now
you've got this new world your physics
world
and again it's some sort of mirrored
version of your game world but instead
of having 3d objects you have physics
objects and you'll use that to simulate
where things go and then sync your 3d
world to it if this doesn't make a whole
lot of sense don't worry we'll do some
code code always makes things clear
so in code the first thing that we have
to actually do is include ammo.js
in my case i just shoved a reference to
it in the index.html file if you're
wondering why there's a wasm version and
a non-wasm version
one is the web assembly compiled version
and that will almost certainly
outperform the other one the next step
is that you have to initialize ammo.js
so down here before i do anything
important i call ammo and supply this
callback
once it's ready to go we can go ahead
and instantiate our world and start
doing actual physics
now i'm mostly using the same code i did
from the tutorial on creating a basic 3d
world i'd like to focus just on the
physics part today so i'm not going to
explain all of that line by line
just watch that first tutorial if none
of this makes sense
here at the top of our initialize
function we've got a bunch of these
funky ammo calls what you're essentially
doing is instantiating your physics
world and choosing which solvers or
broad phase algorithms to use
there's a whole bunch of options for
these there's this 3.js example that
shows off soft body support in bullet
so if you want to have something like
that in your world you need to enable
soft body support which means using the
bt soft rigid dynamics world and bt
default soft body solver yeah i get it
not super clear you can read through the
docs to see what other options there are
but for now we're just going to accept
the basic default values and move on
with our lives
lastly we need to actually update the
physics world every frame so in here in
the raf call we can just call
physicsworld.step simulation and pass
the time elapsed since the last frame
when you run this well
nothing happens
because we haven't actually done
anything yet
all we've done is initialize the physics
engine but we haven't actually placed
anything into the world so let's go do
that now
we need to make what are called rigid
bodies so let's just go ahead and make a
class called rigid body
and what we're going to end up doing is
creating a function we're calling it
create box because it creates boxes no
surprises there
and it'll have a bunch of parameters
like mass position rotation size
that kind of stuff
the first thing that we need to do is
set up the transform and the transform
is exactly like the name implies it's
the initial transform of the rigid body
we set the position and the rotation
with these two calls to set origin and
set rotation
now motion state the way that i
understand this is that this is
basically a way for you to synchronize
the physics world and whatever else you
want in our case graphics
it kind of acts like an interface to get
back the rigid bodies transformed when
you need it
so what we'll be doing later is using
the motion state to update our 3d mesh
transforms
so here we create the shape and this is
interesting because there's a bunch of
predefined shapes in ammo.js things like
cubes spheres cylinders that sort of
thing
in this case we're creating a box shape
and defining the size of the box using
the size parameter but you could make
this a sphere or whatever else bullet
physics supports including a full mesh
like we're not specifically limited to
these basic shapes but in general the
more basic the shape the better the
performance so keep that in mind
finally we create the rigid body using
these couple lines specifically you've
got this line here the bt rigid body
construction info
that sort of acts like a helper to
provide info to create the actual rigid
body on the next line
one important thing to note here is that
we pass the mass into bt rigid body
construction info and as you can see
from the docks setting a mass of zero
creates a fixed or in other words a
non-dynamic rigid body
so basically if you want to create
things that stay in the same spot no
matter what like let's say the ground
set the mass to zero
now if we go and create a box in code
let's create both the 3d mesh
representing the box and the physics
rigid body we'll also create a ground
box and remember to set the mask to zero
here that makes it static and totally
unmovable
and then if you run this well you've got
a box floating in midair a little
anticlimactic if you were expecting it
to fall down but not at all unexpected
let me show you what we did wrong here
remember how i said that we need the
motion state to keep the physics and the
graphics in sync
right that's because that's not
something that just happens
automatically it's code not magic we
need to do this ourselves
so what we can do is create a list of
rigid bodies when we create the 3d mesh
and the ammo.js rigid body we'll group
them together and shove them into the
rigidbodies list
then down below in that step function we
need to do the actual work of syncing
them ourselves
so here what i'm doing is looping over
every rigid body in our list which is
realistically just one box
and i'm using the motion state to access
the transform
from the transform we can get the origin
and rotation create three dot js vectors
out of those
and copy them into the mesh's position
and rotation
now when you do that
voila you've got a box and it falls from
the sky onto the ground so yay we're
making progress
diving back into the code here what i'm
doing here is looping and creating a
whole bunch of objects
but this time instead of just creating
boxes we're going to create boxes and
spheres
crazy fancy
that means that i have to create this
new function create sphere
which is in reality mostly a copy paste
of the other create box function with
one extremely minor difference
see this line here the bt sphere shape
that's pretty much the difference
instead of creating a box we create a
sphere
if i wanted to clean this up a bit
better we'd refactor this to be a more
general function but whatever this is a
tutorial
now we've got a whole bunch of boxes and
spheres falling
pretty neat
and that about wraps up getting the
basics working this is kind of just
scratching the surface of what's
possible with ammo.js but should be
enough for you to get the ball rolling
at least
pun intended
codes up on github probably if i
remembered so take a look
until next time cheers